We'd like to consider
velocity-dependent resistive
forces.
So let's imagine a situation
where we have an object,
and it's falling in a
gravitational field,
so we have a
gravitational force.
And this object is like a
marble falling in a vat of oil.
And there is a
velocity-dependent resistive
force that is acting
on this object.
And let's again choose the
positive direction down.
And now for objects that are
moving very slowly in a fluid,
let's make a model for our
velocity-dependent resistive
force.
We will assume that
the resistive force is
proportional to
the velocity, it's
opposing the
direction of motion,
and we'll put a
coefficient alpha in front.
And this is our model for
velocity-dependent resistive
forces for objects that
are moving very slowly.
For our case, let's consider the
units of the coefficient alpha.
So the units of
alpha have the units
of force divided by velocity.
So the units of force are-- we
have the units of force divided
by the units of
velocity, and that
gives us kilogram meter
per second squared, divided
by the units of velocity,
which are velocity per second.
And so we see that the
coefficient of alpha
has the units of kilogram
per inverse second.
Now what we'd like to do is
apply Newton's Second Law.
So let's analyze the forces
and get the equation of motion
for this object falling
in a viscous medium
with a resistive force.
In the j hat direction, we
have the gravitational force.
And we have our
resistive friction force,
which we're writing Vy as the
y component of the velocity.
And that's equal
to m times dVy dt.
Now notice that
the acceleration--
we're not treating
as a constant.
It's a derivative
of the velocity.
This leads us to our
differential equation, which
is written as dy dt--
I'll divide through
by m-- g minus alpha over m, Vy.
Now this is a linear
and velocity first order
differential equation with
a constant term in here,
which is called inhomogeneous
linear first order differential
equation.
We shall solve this like we
did with our other equations
by separation of variables.
So what we do is we
bring the velocity terms
to one side and the time
terms to the other side.
And now we can integrate
both sides directly.
But before I
integrate this side,
I'd like to rewrite it
by writing it as dVy--
and I'd like to pull out
a minus alpha over m.
And this term here becomes
minus mg over alpha.
Why did I do this?
For the integration, it just
makes my natural logarithm
interval look a
little bit easier.
And over here, I had dt.
Now what I want to
do is integrate.
And we're going to integrate
from some initial velocity,
which we're going
to take to be 0,
we're going to let this
object be released from rest,
and we're going to integrate
to some final speed Vy of t.
Over here, let's just call our
integration variable t prime.
And we integrate t prime
from 0 to some time t.
So this is our variable and the
velocity as a function of time.
Now doing this
interval-- first off,
this constant term comes out.
So we have 1 over
minus alpha over m.
And the interval is just
a natural log integral
of Vy minus mg over alpha.
And we have to divide that
in the lower limit, Vy is 0,
and we have just
minus mg over alpha.
And this side is very simply t.
Now we can rewrite this
equation by bringing the m
over alpha to the other side.
And we have log of Vy minus
mg alpha, over minus mg alpha,
equals minus alpha m t.
Now recall that e to the log of
any quantity x is equal to x.
So if I exponentiate
both sides, I
get Vy minus mg over alpha,
divided by minus mg alpha,
is equal to the exponential
e to the minus alpha m t.
Now the last step is simply
to bring this over to there,
multiply, and do a
little bit of algebra.
And so I get that the
velocity as a function of y
is equal to mg alpha times 1
minus e to the minus alpha m t.
Now there's a few
interesting things here
that we want to look at.
Suppose we define
this exponential e
to the minus alpha m t as equal
to e to the minus t over tau,
where tau is m over alpha.
The units of tau, when
we look at the units,
it has the units
of mass, which is
kilograms, over the units of
alpha, which we worked out
before.
So we have kilograms over
kilogram inverse second.
That gives us units of seconds.
And that's what we would expect
because t seconds over seconds
gives us dimensionless
quantity for the exponential.
Now the last thing
we'd like to look at
is let's just see what
happens when we plot this.
Well, if we're plotting
Vy as a function of t,
we start off at 0.
And we're going to reach
some terminal quantity Vy
terminal, which is when
we have a graph like that.
And we can see what
that terminal speed
is when we set t
equal to infinity,
e to the minus infinity is 0.
And so this terminal speed is
equal to just this coefficient,
mg over alpha.
And that's the terminal speed.
Now notice, that as a
check for what we did,
we can come back to our
differential equation,
and what does
terminal speed mean?
Notice that when you
get to this limit,
as t approaches infinity, the
slope of the velocity curve
is zero.
And that's really the
statement over here
that Vy terminal is when the
velocity is no longer changing
in time.
You can see it graphically.
And this is the statement, when
we go back to Newton's Second
Law, that acceleration is 0.
So the sum of the forces
at terminal speed is 0,
the resistive force is equal
to the gravitational force,
and so from this equation
here, as a check,
we can see that Vy terminal
equals mg over alpha, which
checks with our calculation.
And so we have confidence that
we analyzed this correctly.
And that gives us our motion.
One last thing that's
quite interesting.
Notice that the terminal
speed depends on mass.
This coefficient alpha
is only a function
of the properties
of the object--
the size, the shape,
the geometric properties
of the object, not
how dense it is.
So if you have two objects,
like two balls, same radius,
but one was denser than the
other, then the other mass
would be heavier and
the terminal speed
would be greater.
So what we see is that two
identical objects, one heavier
than the other,
the heavier object
reaches a faster terminal speed
than the lighter object, which
explains a well
observed phenomenon.